right is it fair to say the criticism  Democrats give to the right is the way  they manipulate elections is through  gerrymandering and that's kind of what  they specialize in yes and the criticism  Republicans will give the left is they  do election fraud and that's kind of how  they do it to win elections so it's like  hey if you're going to do Jerry Manor  we're going to do this but if you're  going to do this we're going to do that  is that a fair criticism that each side  gives to the other side I think to  varying degrees they're both guilty of  that because I think the Republicans  more so on the gerrymandering right I  think Democrats more so on the stealing  votes but let me tell you Republicans in  places that they control stuff and no  one's looking human nature and being  what it is they're taking some votes too  it's how it is it's sort of built in to  the system it should be fixed it must be  fixed so we can trust our country and  our democracy